WHITNEY BOUCK: Box is
a Cloud based platform
and an application,
both for end users
to more effectively share
business information,
work with their colleagues
in a more effective way then
they've been able to do before.
Box is currently serving over
200,000 unique businesses
around the world.
Very, very small
mom and pop shops,
companies of even
three to five people,
all the way up to some of the
world's largest organizations
that are multinational
in nature.
DAVID MAYNARD: More then
half of our Android users
come from outside
the United States.
WHITNEY BOUCK:
Android-like Box, I think,
has this wonderful openness
and kind of natural traction.
You get a lot of
adoption virally.
You get a lot of people who
really love their Android
device.
So I love the fact that we share
a common philosophy in openness
for our customers.
DAVID MAYNARD: We've seen
over five million downloads
on the Android application
on both phones and tablets.
SIMON TAN: I'm real
excited that Box
has such a big focus
on mobile right now.
We have a full suite
of mobile apps.
Box from Android is starting
to pick up a lot of traction
in the enterprise as well.
DAVID MAYNARD:
The Android system
makes localization
easy and simple.
SIMON TAN: And also
Android is really flexible.
So there's a lot of things
we can do on Android that we
can't do on other platforms.
The developer console helps us
understand our user base more
and let's us see
where they are from,
let's us see what
devices they're
using, what version of
Android they're running.
Lets us see the reviews
and ratings, let's
us respond to those reviews.
DAVID MAYNARD: What I love
about the Android platform
is that we control how fast
we iterate on the product
and what we ship to
consumers and when.
We also love the
fact that we can
do rolling roll outs of
the product we tested.
We typically roll out a
new release to about 10%
of our user base.
And we monitor how the
application is behaving.
We monitor both performance
and usage of the application.
And typically
after a half a day,
we roll it out to
50% of our user base.
And perhaps after 24
hours, we roll out to 100%.
It's been a great help in
making sure our application is
flawless.
One of the examples of
leading the future on Android
is the ability to add
collaborators to folders.
The first mobile implementation
of that was on Android.
Android is a great platform
for integrating and getting
consumer feedback and enterprise
feedback very quickly.